chez caractérisé à l'instant la
situation épidémique dans notre pays je
le rappelle un plateau haut qui augmente
une incidence qui augmente une pression
sur l'hôpital qui augmente
une diffusion des variants qui est à
l'évidence importante et rapide et c'est
dans ces conditions que nous avions
appris en anticipation le couvre-feu
avancé à 18 heures il ya des expressions
scientifique nombreuses c'est important
il y à des expressions du président du
conseil scientifique le professeur
delfraissy qui a lui-même a considéré
qu'il était important de mesurer
pleinement les effets du couvre-feu à
18h et c'est ce que nous faisons mais ce
que je disais à l'instant c'est que nous
travaillons en anticipation de cette de
ce point d'étape qui sera fait de cet
ses conclusions qui seront tirées sur le
couvre-feu à 18h au bout des deux
semaines qui avait été l'engagement du
premier ministre parce que nous
considérons je le disais à l'instant que
le couvre-feu à 18h à ce stade en effet
une efficacité relative qui est réel
mais qui n'est pas suffisante
à ce stade c'est donc en anticipation
avant de tirer les conclusions au bout
des deux semaines que nous envisageons
plusieurs scénarios pour répondre à vos
questions ce sont plusieurs scénarios
qui vont d'un maintien du cadre actuel
avec le couvre-feu à 18h jusqu'à un
confinement très serré